self-sabotage has to do with a  deep-seated belief that you're  undeserving of good things if you  conduct some self-sabotage then you can  say well i didn't really try you're  opting out of putting yourself  on the line you need to perform an  inventory of your life and identify the  stories that defy that narrative think  of all the times where good things did  happen or you  were deserving of love or whatever it is  that you feel like you're you're lacking  and then moving forward is all about  performing esteemable acts because  self-esteem is a result of the  performance of a steamable act it's a  muscle it's a habit just like anything  else to turn it around like you're going  to have to practice this for long  periods of time